It's a little ritual that Parker invented for herself and it's always the same, every year. Around this time of year, February 2, to be exact.
这是帕克为自己发明的一个小仪式，而且每年都一样。确切地说，是在每年的这个时候，2月2日。
February 2, which is Groundhog Day, at 10:30 at night, I turn on the movie Groundhog Day.
2月2日，也就是土拨鼠日，晚上10点半，我会打开电影《土拨鼠之日》。
Rita, I'm reliving the same day over and over. Groundhog Day.
丽塔，我正在一遍又一遍地过着同一天。土拨鼠日。
Groundhog Day, of course, is the 1993 Bill Murray comedy about a self-centered weatherman who gets trapped in time, repeating the same day again and again, a day where he covers a Groundhog Day ceremony on local TV.
当然，《土拨鼠之日》是1993年比尔·默瑞主演的一部喜剧，讲述了一个以自我为中心的气象预报员被困在时间循环中，不断重复着同一天的故事，那一天他要去当地电视台报道土拨鼠日的仪式。
Once a year, the eyes of the nation turn to this tiny Hamlet in Western Pennsylvania to watch a master at work. The master, Punxsutawney Phil, the world's most famous weatherman, the Groundhog, who, as legend has it, can predict the coming of an early spring.
每年，全世界的目光都会投向宾夕法尼亚州西部这个偏僻的小村庄，观看一位大师的表演。这位大师就是菲尔，世界上最著名的气象员——那只土拨鼠，传说它能预示早春的到来。
Bill Murray spends the whole film repeating February 2nd.
比尔·默瑞在整部电影中都在重复过2月2日。
Well, it's Groundhog Day again.
好吧，又是土拨鼠日了。
Until, finally, at the end of the film, he unsticks himself in time and wakes up on the next day. Again, here's Parker.
直到电影最后，他终于跳出了时间循环，在第二天醒来。帕克又来了。
I time it up so that when it's around midnight, when it's February 3 in the world, it's February 3 in the movie. So when it's February 3 in the movie, it becomes February 3 in the world, which is my birthday. So I do it as, I call it, like I'm slowly boiling myself into my birthday.
我算好了时间，当午夜临近，世界上变成了2月3日时，电影里也正好是2月3日。所以当电影里到了2月3日，现实世界也变成了2月3日，也就是我的生日。我称之为“慢慢煮进我的生日”。
Parker says she's not a big birthday person, but this is a little thing she's done for herself to mark the day ever since she was 22. First saw Groundhog Day in a film class.
帕克说她不是那种很看重生日的人，但这确实是她从22岁起为了纪念这一天而为自己做的小仪式。她第一次看《土拨鼠之日》是在一门电影课上。
I was in a program where I was the only Black person, the only woman. Everyone was 10 years older than me.
我在那个项目里是唯一的黑人，唯一的女性。其他人比我大10岁。
Oh, wow. This was like film studies?
哦，哇。那是电影研究吗？
This was film school, yeah. But so it was just it was a very lonely place.
那是电影学校，是的。所以那是一个非常孤独的地方。
So she created this birthday movie night for herself to do alone, that she still does alone every year with the film Groundhog Day, that she's going to do this year for the 16th time. And maybe you think that means that she's really into the film Groundhog Day. Nope.
于是她为自己创造了这个独自享用的生日电影之夜，她至今仍每年独自观看《土拨鼠之日》，今年将是第16次。也许你认为这意味着她真的很喜欢《土拨鼠之日》。不。
I don't love the movie. The movie's fine. Like, it's OK. I don't mind it. It's not my brand of humor. Also, I don't know, in the 21st century, some of the stuff is fairly problematic.
我不喜欢这部电影。电影还行。就像，还可以。我不介意看它。这不是我喜欢的幽默类型。而且，我不知道，在21世纪，里面的一些东西相当有问题。
So, like, for instance?
比如呢？
Well, there's whole sequences where Phil Connor, who is Bill Murray's character, is trying to seduce two women, and he keeps repeating the day so he can ascertain information to seduce them.
嗯，有整整几个片段，菲尔·康纳——也就是比尔·默瑞的角色——试图引诱两名女性，他不断重复这一天，以便掌握信息来引诱她们。
Can I buy you a drink?
能请你喝一杯吗？
OK. Sweet vermouth on the rocks with a twist, please.
好的。请给我来一杯加冰的甜苦艾酒，加一片柠檬皮。
So it's not like known consent.
所以这不是知情的同意。
Right. So he's tricking them into it?
对。所以他在欺骗她们？
He's tricking them into hooking up with him.
他在骗她们跟他上床。
Can I buy you a drink?
能请你喝一杯吗？
OK.
好的。
Sweet vermouth, rocks with a twist, please.
甜苦艾酒，加冰，加一片柠檬皮，谢谢。
That's my favorite drink.
那是我的最爱。
Mine, too. It always makes me think of Rome, the way the sun hits the buildings in the afternoon.
也是我的。它总让我想起罗马，想起午后阳光照在建筑物上的样子。
Parker says there are lots of films she'd much rather be watching once a year, year after year. Like her favorite film, Point Break, the Keanu Reeves surfing film.
帕克说有很多电影她更愿意每年都看一遍。比如她最喜欢的电影《惊爆点》，基努·里维斯主演的冲浪电影。
That, I can watch forever and not be mad about. That's fine. But the past, however long years I've watched Groundhog Day, again, it's fine.
那部我可以看一辈子都不会腻。没问题。但过去这些年我看的《土拨鼠之日》，还是那句话，还可以。
It's fine--
还可以——
It's fine.
还可以。
But you do it every year.
但你每年都看。
Maybe I don't totally understand why I still do it, like, for so long, but it works for me. It's a thing that I can do for myself, by myself. And the repetition is comforting, even if I'm forcing myself to do it. I'm not a person who's good at repetition. I got ADHD. My brain's all over the place. But February 2, 10:30 PM, I can turn on Groundhog Day. I know what I'm getting into, and then I am absorbed by the movie. And then all of a sudden it ends and I go, oh, that's right, it's after midnight. I was born. There's a comfort in that.
也许我并不完全明白为什么我坚持看了这么久，但它对我有效。这是我可以独自为自己做的一件事。这种重复是令人安慰的，即使我是强迫自己去做的。我不擅长重复。我有ADHD（注意缺陷多动障碍）。我的大脑总是天马行空。但2月2日晚上10点半，我可以打开《土拨鼠之日》。我知道我在做什么，然后我就沉浸在电影里了。突然电影结束了，我就想，噢，对了，已经过午夜了。我出生了。这其中有一种安慰感。
But the thing that makes it feel comforting is the repetition and it's a movie about how awful repetition is.
但让你感到安慰的事情是“重复”，而这正是一部关于“重复”有多可怕的电影。
Yeah, there's an irony to it, I'm aware. But I like the repetition. Groundhog Day, the repetition is awful, but the end result of the repetition isn't half bad.
是的，这很讽刺，我知道。但我喜欢这种重复。《土拨鼠之日》里重复是可怕的，但重复的结果并不算太坏。
Like, Phil, totally improves himself. He learns how to be a considerate human being. One of the last things he says to Andie MacDowell in the movie is, What can I do for you?
比如，菲尔彻底提升了自己。他学会了做一个体贴的人。他在电影中对安迪·麦克道威尔说的最后一句话是：“我能为你做些什么？”
Today on our program, for Groundhog Day, the power of repetition, how it can be utterly devastating to do something you love dozens of times or hundreds of times. You can rob it of all feeling. You can turn it into drudgery. But repetition can also do the opposite.
今天在我们的节目中，关于土拨鼠日，探讨重复的力量，探讨做一件你热爱的事几十次或几百次会是多么令人沮丧。你会剥夺它所有的情感。你会把它变成苦差事。但重复也可以起到相反的作用。
The more you do something, the more you can find in it and live in it. I've said these next few words hundreds of times, and I say them today excited for what is to come this hour. From WBEZ Chicago, This American Life, I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
你做得越多，你就能在其中发现更多，活得更深。接下来的这几句话我已经说了几百次了，但我今天依然为这一小时即将发生的事情感到兴奋。这里是WBEZ芝加哥电台，《这一美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
This American Life, Act One, "Will You Still Slug Me Tomorrow?" Sometimes, choosing to repeat the same moment over and over again is an act of love. Aviva DeKornfeld has this true life example.
《这一美国生活》，第一幕，“明天你还会打我吗？”有时，选择一遍又一遍地重复同一时刻是一种爱的行为。阿维瓦·德科恩菲尔德有这个真实的生活案例。
Bridie and her dad, Brin, have been playing the same game for decades. It's called a pinch and a punch.
布里迪和她的父亲布林几十年来一直在玩同一个游戏。它叫做“捏一下，捶一下”。
The rules of the game are, you say, "Pinch and a punch. First day of the month. No returns." Obviously, the no returns is important. When I was little, when we started doing this, we would gently, of course, actually do the little pinch and a punch first day of the month.
游戏的规则是，你说：“捏一下，捶一下。月初第一天。概不退还。”显然，“概不退还”很重要。小时候，当我们刚开始做这个时，我们当然会轻轻地真的去捏和捶对方一下，在月初的第一天。
One of them would actually pinch and punch the other.
他们中的一个会真的捏并捶另一个一下。
But over the years, as the way we've done it has become more inventive and stylish, and now that we live in different countries, obviously, the physical element is kind of removed. So it is often just something written down or over the phone.
但多年来，随着我们玩游戏的方式变得更有创意、更时髦，而且现在我们住不同的国家，显然，肢体接触这种元素已经去除了。所以这通常只是写下来的东西或者通过电话沟通。
OK, so it can be any form, it just has to reach the other person?
好的，所以可以是任何形式，只要传达到对方就行？
Yes.
是的。
Before their pinch and punch reaches you?
在他们的“捏一下，捶一下”传达到你之前？
That's right.
没错。
They first started playing this game when Bridie was really little. She can't really remember ever not playing it. It was just one of the many games they played. Brin traveled a lot for work when Bridie was young, and the games were a way for them to stay connected while he was gone. But pinch and punch, this is the game that stuck. It kept going for years and really leveled up when Bridie was in secondary school. One day, when Bridie was 14--
他们第一次玩这个游戏是在布里迪还很小的时候。她甚至不记得自己什么时候没玩过这个游戏。这只是他们玩的众多游戏之一。布里迪小时候，布林因为工作经常出差，这些游戏是他们在他离开时保持联系的一种方式。但“捏一下，捶一下”，这个游戏坚持了下来。它持续了很多年，并在布里迪上中学时真正升级了。有一天，当布里迪14岁时——
I got pulled out of class and sent to the principal's office. So I immediately assumed I was in deep trouble. And I was a very good kid at school. I never did anything naughty, so going to the principal's office was really out of character, so I was immediately terrified.
我被从课堂里叫出来，送到了校长办公室。所以我立刻以为我惹了大麻烦。我是个乖学生。我从没做过任何淘气的事，所以去校长办公室真的很反常，所以我当时吓坏了。
So I walk to the principal's office, and there's the principal. There's this other guy holding a fancy looking envelope. I open the envelope, message for Bridie Connell, and it's pinch and a punch first day of the month, no returns.
我走到校长办公室，校长在那里。还有另一个拿着一个看起来很高级信封的男人。我打开信封，上面写着给布里迪·康奈尔的消息，是“捏一下，捶一下，月初第一天，概不退还”。
And I think, at that point, in dad's mind, I'm pretty sure he's gone, OK, well, I've escalated this game to the highest degree. She's never going to come back from that. But I think he forgets that he has passed on his extreme competitiveness to me. And from then, it kind of kicked off.
我想，在当时我爸爸的心里，我敢肯定他在想，好吧，我已经把这个游戏升级到最高等级了。她永远也赢不回来了。但我认为他忘了他也把极度的竞争心传给了我。从那时起，游戏就开始了。
These days, now that Bridie is grown up and moved out, most of the pinches and punches are low key, a phone call, a text. Sometimes Brin or Bridie will try to disguise the sentence in an email sent to the whole family. Bridie says her dad has learned to not open anything from her that's sent just to him on the first of the month. So month in and month out, Brin and Bridie are living in this very specific type of loop, where in order for them to stay in the loop, they have to keep changing it, inventing new ways to win.
现在布里迪长大了搬出去了，大部分的“捏和捶”都很低调，一个电话，一条短信。有时布林或布里迪会试图把这句话藏在发给全家人的邮件里。布里迪说她爸爸已经学会了不打开月初发来的、只发给他一个人的任何东西。所以月复一月，布林和布里迪一直生活在这种非常特定的循环中，为了保持这个循环，他们必须不断地改变它，发明新的赢球方式。
Once, a few years ago, Bridie had to get jaw surgery on the first of the month. Her dad was her next of kin, and so she mocked up a fake medical form for her dad to sign, and convinced the nurse to tuck her fake form in with the rest. Bridie proudly won that month. That was kind of a famous win for her, actually, because while Bridie wins more often, her dad's wins tend to be more memorable. His have more flair.
有一次，几年前，布里迪在月初那天要做下颌手术。她爸爸是她的直系亲属，所以她伪造了一份医疗表格让她爸爸签，并说服护士把她的假表格夹在其他文件里。布里迪自豪地赢得了那个月。那实际上是她的一次著名胜利，因为虽然布里迪赢的次数更多，但她爸爸的胜利往往更令人难忘。他的更有风头。
Like once, he convinced Bridie's best friend to interrupt her own wedding to deliver a pinch and punch. He even got Bridie while she was on live radio. The family is from New Zealand, but Bridie lives and works in Sydney, where she was a guest on this weekly local radio show and Brin conspired with the host to get her on air.
比如有一次，他说服了布里迪最好的朋友在自己的婚礼上打断仪式来传递一个“捏和捶”。他甚至在布里迪上电台直播时抓住了她。他们家来自新西兰，但布里迪在悉尼生活和工作，她是当地一个每周广播节目的嘉宾，布林与主持人串通好让她在节目中中招。
(INTERVIEWER) RADIO SHOW HOST: Hey, Bridie.
（采访者）电台主持人：嘿，布里迪。
Yes?
在吗？
(INTERVIEWER) RADIO SHOW HOST 1: I got an email today from New Zealand. I don't often get emails from New Zealand.
（采访者）电台主持人1：我今天收到一封来自新西兰的邮件。我不常收到新西兰的邮件。
(INTERVIEWER) RADIO SHOW HOST 2: But thankfully, you have also been trained in the internet.
（采访者）电台主持人2：但谢天谢地，你也受过互联网训练。
(INTERVIEWER) RADIO SHOW HOST 1: Yeah. It was from--
（采访者）电台主持人1：是啊。它来自——
Was it from mom or dad?
是妈妈还是爸爸？
(INTERVIEWER) RADIO SHOW HOST 1: Do a man called Brin Connell? Brin Connell?
（采访者）电台主持人1：一个叫布林·康奈尔的人？布林·康奈尔？
OK, that is my dad. Yep.
好吧，那是我爸爸。是的。
(INTERVIEWER) RADIO SHOW HOST 1: We had a long discussion about the seasons, days of the month, New Zealand time, being--
（采访者）电台主持人1：我们关于季节、月份的日子、新西兰时间进行了一次漫长的讨论，作为——
Oh no you didn't.
哦，不，你们没这样做吧。
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
(INTERVIEWER) RADIO SHOW HOST 1: A pinch and a punch for the first of the month. He says, on his understanding--
（采访者）电台主持人1：“捏一下，捶一下”，月初第一天。他说，根据他的理解——
Over time, the rules have evolved. No middle of the night calls. You have to respect time zones. Also, the game is formally suspended on New Year's Eve, since Bridie and Brin would hijack the countdown for their game, And according to Bridie's mom, kept, quote, "ruining the holiday." Bridie says her dad escalated the game to a whole new level in 2019. She was flying home to New Zealand for her cousin Jeremy's 30th birthday party, and the flight was on May 1st, very early in the morning.
随着时间的推移，规则也演变了。不能半夜打电话。你必须尊重时区。此外，游戏在除夕夜正式暂停，因为布里迪和布林会为了他们的游戏劫持倒计时，而且根据布里迪妈妈的话说，他们一直在“破坏节日”。布里迪说，2019年她爸爸把游戏升级到了一个全新的高度。当时她正飞回新西兰参加她表弟杰里米的30岁生日派对，航班是在5月1日清晨。
And, as you know, have rules about really, really, really early morning wake-up calls and pinch and a punch calls are not allowed, and they haven't been allowed for years. So I thought, I'm just going to have to wait. I'm just going to have to hope that by the time I arrive in New Zealand, which will still be fairly early, that dad's forgotten and I can get in there and win for the month of May.
而且，正如你们所知，对于非常、非常、非常早的清晨唤醒电话和“捏和捶”电话有规则，这些是不允许的，而且多年来都不允许。所以我心想，我只能等着。我只能希望等我到达新西兰时，时间还算早，而且爸爸忘了，我可以趁机赢得五月份的比赛。
And then that was all I thought about it. And then I got onto the plane, I boarded, I took my seat. And I sat down on the plane. And then about five minutes later, while everyone's still filing into the plane, the cabin manager comes up to me and says, oh, excuse me, Miss Connell, you've been moved.
然后这就是我想的一切。我上了飞机，登机，找到了座位。我坐在飞机上。大约五分钟后，当大家还在登机时，客舱经理走到我面前说，哦，不好意思，康奈尔小姐，你的座位换了。
The flight attendant tells her she's getting bumped up to premium economy and brings her to her new seat.
空乘人员告诉她，她被升到了高级经济舱，并把她带到了新座位。
And then he said, oh, by the way, I've got something for you. And he handed me an envelope. And I just thought, oh, maybe I'm about to be-- maybe this is part of the premium economy service. Maybe it's a menu. I don't know what it is. As you can tell, I am not used to that premium economy life.
然后他说，哦，对了，我有东西给你。他递给我一个信封。我心想，哦，也许我是要——也许这是高级经济舱服务的一部分。也许是菜单。我不知道是什么。如你所见，我不习惯那种高级经济舱的生活。
And I opened the envelope and it was a letter from my dad saying, "I hope you have a great flight. I can't wait to see you when you land. And also, just something to reflect on while you're winging your way across the Tasman, pinch and a punch first day of the month. No returns."
我打开信封，那是我爸爸的一封信，上面写着：“希望你飞行愉快。我迫不及待地想在你着陆时见到你。还有，当你飞越塔斯曼海时，反思一下这件事：捏一下，捶一下，月初第一天。概不退还。”
She spent the rest of the flight thinking about how she would get him back. Luckily for Bridie, Air New Zealand is apparently extremely into pranks and offered to help. So together, they made a fake Father's Day themed ad for the airline. Air New Zealand actually got real pilots and flight attendants to appear in this short video, which Bridie wrote, and then she got her mom to show it to her dad.
她在飞行的剩余时间里都在想怎么报复他。幸运的是，新西兰航空公司似乎非常喜欢恶作剧，并主动提出帮忙。于是，他们一起制作了一个假的父亲节主题广告。新西兰航空公司甚至让真正的飞行员和空乘人员出现在这段短视频中，视频由布里迪撰写，然后她让妈妈给爸爸看。
(SUBJECT) WOMAN IN AD 1: It's Father's day in New Zealand, and we want to say thanks to all the amazing dads out there.
（对象）广告中的女子1：这是新西兰的父亲节，我们要感谢所有了不起的父亲们。
(SUBJECT) MAN IN AD 1: Thank you--
（对象）广告中的男子1：谢谢——
Started off, thank you for being such a wonderful dad. Well, that's generic.
开头是：谢谢你成为这么棒的父亲。好吧，那很普通。
This, of course, is Brin Connell. The video starts out thanking dads for doing regular dad stuff, but as it progresses, it starts getting more and more specific, naming things Brin has actually done.
当然，这就是布林·康奈尔。视频开头感谢父亲们做一些常规的父亲事，但随着进展，它开始变得越来越具体，列举了布林实际做过的事情。
Yeah. Thank you for building me a fort when I was young. I'm thinking, oh, I did that. And they were saying things like, thank you for your really bad dad jokes, someone would say. And I go, oh, I do that. Thank you for cooking such great roast dinners. Oh, I do that as well. [CHUCKLES] I was naive.
是啊。谢谢你在我小时候为我建堡垒。我在想，哦，我确实做过。然后他们说诸如“谢谢你糟糕的冷笑话”之类的话，我就说，哦，我确实这样。谢谢你做的这么棒的烤肉晚餐。哦，我也做那个。（轻笑）我太天真了。
(SUBJECT) MAN IN AD 2: We love your generosity--
（对象）广告中的男子2：我们爱你的慷慨——
(SUBJECT) WOMAN IN AD 2: Your spirit--
（对象）广告中的女子2：你的精神——
And then a female pilot came on and said, That means you, Brin Connell.
然后一位女飞行员走过来，说：就是你，布林·康奈尔。
(SUBJECT) WOMAN IN AD 3: Yes, you.
（对象）广告中的女子3：是的，就是你。
(SUBJECT) WOMAN IN AD 4: Brin Connell, you're always playing jokes.
（对象）广告中的女子4：布林·康奈尔，你总是爱开玩笑。
And then when the video changes and it becomes clear that they're talking to him, he just obviously does not compute for, like, 10 seconds. And then he was like, What? What? What? What? Hey, hang on.
然后当视频切换，清楚地表明他们是在对他说话时，他显然呆滞了大概10秒钟。然后他说，什么？什么？什么？什么？嘿，等等。
There are 12 firsts of the month each year, and Bridie and Brin have been playing this game for roughly 25 years. So they've done hundreds of pinches and punches at this point. The thing about having such a long running game, though, is that life happens all around it, all the good and bad. A few years ago, Bridie lost someone very close to her.
每年有12个月初的第一天，布里迪和布林玩这个游戏已经大约25年了。所以到目前为止，他们已经进行了数百次“捏和捶”。然而，玩这么长时间的游戏，生活总是在它周围发生，无论好坏。几年前，布里迪失去了一位非常亲近的人。
Over the period of this tragedy, the first of the month rolled around. And I thought, should I do something or not? Because she was feeling very bruised and lonely and desperate, and I chose to. And it was just something that she could reach out to and go, yeah, dad's here. It's OK. And she just came out to me later and gave me a big cuddle and said, that's just what I needed. Thank you, Daddy.
在这场悲剧期间，月初到了。我想，我应该做点什么吗？因为她感到非常受伤、孤独和绝望，但我选择了这样做。这只是她可以伸手去触碰的东西，说，是的，爸爸在这儿。没关系。她后来找到我，给了我一个大大的拥抱，说，这正是我需要的。谢谢你，爸爸。
And she only calls me daddy on very rare occasions. And I can't even remember what it was. I think it was just something fairly banal that month, but it was, I'm in your corner, honey. I'm still here.
她很少叫我爸爸。我甚至不记得那次是什么了。我想那个月只是些平凡的事情，但那是：我支持你，亲爱的。我还在这里。
There's a lie built into the premise of pinch and punch. It's when they say no returns. They say it every month, and every month, they return.
“捏和捶”的前提中内置了一个谎言。就是他们说“概不退还”的时候。他们每个月都这么说，但每个月，他们都会反击。
Aviva DeKornfeld is a producer on our show.
阿维瓦·德科恩菲尔德是我们节目的制作人。
Act Two, "I'll Repeat the Question." So our show today is about Groundhog Day and what repeating the same thing over and over can accomplish or reveal. And I don't want to say much about this next item before it starts, except to say that it is a common thing when radio reporters sit down to interview somebody, we have to set the record volume properly. So we need the interviewee to just say some words about something while we set recording levels. And so we'll ask them some kind of neutral question, to describe the route they took to work that morning or what they had for breakfast. This comes from radio producer Talia Augustidis.
第二幕，“我会重复这个问题。”我们今天的节目是关于土拨鼠日的，以及一遍又一遍地重复同一件事能达成或揭示什么。在开始这一段之前，我不想多说，除了说当电台记者坐下来采访某人时，我们需要正确设置录音音量，这是一件很普通的事情。所以我们需要受访者随便说些关于某事的话，同时我们调整录音电平。所以我们会问他们一个中立的问题，比如描述他们那天早上上班的路线，或者他们早餐吃了什么。这一段来自电台制作人塔莉亚·奥古斯蒂迪斯。
This needs to be actually quite close to you.
这需要离你真的很近。
OK.
好的。
Can you tell me what you had for breakfast so I can check the levels?
你能告诉我你早餐吃了什么吗，这样我能检查电平？
Yes. The answer is probably I can't remember. Oh, no-- porridge, porridge. Porridge and blueberries.
是的。答案可能是：我想不起来了。哦，不——燕麦粥，燕麦粥。燕麦粥和蓝莓。
You always have the same thing for breakfast.
你早餐总是吃一样的东西。
Yes.
是的。
It's not hard to remember. OK. Porridge and blueberries.
这不难记。好吧。燕麦粥和蓝莓。
Do you want to tell me what you've had for breakfast this morning?
你想告诉我你今天早上早餐吃了什么吗？
Well, if I can remember. Oh, yes. I had-- I had--
嗯，如果我记得的话。哦，是的。我吃了——我吃了——
There's a hint.
有个提示。
Porridge.
燕麦粥。
Yeah, it's over there.
是的，就在那儿。
Porridge and delicious berries.
燕麦粥和美味的浆果。
Do you want to tell me what you had for breakfast this morning?
你想告诉我你今天早上早餐吃了什么吗？
Honestly, I can't remember. Oh, yes I can. It's porridge, as usual.
老实说，我想不起来了。哦，是的，我想起来了。燕麦粥，照常。
I'm just going to check the levels. So do you remember what we do to check the levels?
我只是要检查一下电平。那么你还记得我们要怎么检查电平吗？
No.
不记得。
What did you have for breakfast this morning?
你今天早上早餐吃了什么？
Porridge. And berries.
燕麦粥。还有浆果。
So OK. I just need to check the levels. Do you remember what we do to check the levels?
好的。我只是需要检查电平。你记得我们要怎么检查电平吗？
Well, we talked about what I had for breakfast.
嗯，我们谈了早餐吃了什么。
Yes.
是的。
OK. So I had-- did we have it for breakfast? Anyway, it was-- it was lovely. Just a loose mouthful. I'm sorry. It just takes so long.
好的。所以我吃了——我们早餐吃了它吗？不管怎样，它——它很棒。只是一大口。抱歉。这太花时间了。
No, that's OK. Let me just check the levels. What did you have for breakfast this morning?
不，没关系。让我检查一下电平。你今天早上早餐吃了什么？
Same as usual, which, of course, I can't remember.
像往常一样，当然，我记不起来了。
It's in your mouth. What does it taste like, then?
就在你嘴里。那尝起来是什么味道呢？
It tastes absolutely delicious.
尝起来绝对美味。
I'm flattered. What did you have for breakfast this morning?
我受宠若惊。你今天早上早餐吃了什么？
I had-- I had-- I was going to say breakfast. I had-- I'm so sorry.
我吃了——我吃了——我本想说早餐。我吃了——我很抱歉。
That's OK. Don't worry if you can't remember, we'll just-- do you want a different question?
没关系。别担心，如果你记不起来了，我们会——你想要个不同的问题吗？
Yes.
是的。
What did you have for breakfast today?
你今天早餐吃了什么？
I probably had porridge and-- stuff. Yeah, nice things.
我可能吃了燕麦粥和——杂七杂八的东西。是的，好吃的。
You didn't eat much of it today. Should we do that before we start? Just try a bit more?
你今天没吃多少。我们在开始前要不要先做那个？试着多吃一点？
No, I can't.
不，我不能。
OK.
好的。
No.
不。
Let's start then.
那我们开始吧。
Sorry, it's a bit quick. I might not manage this.
抱歉，这有点快。我可能应付不来。
Maybe we shouldn't do the recording today.
也许我们今天不该录音了。
Oh, dear. Oh, dear. OK.
哦，天哪。哦，天哪。好吧。
That story from Talia Augustidis. She's the creator of the podcast Unreality. She first produced this story for Shortcuts, a Falling Tree production for BBC Radio 4.
那个故事来自塔莉亚·奥古斯蒂迪斯。她是播客《非现实》的创作者。她最初为BBC第四电台的“Falling Tree”制作公司制作了这个故事。
Act Three, "Raiders of the Lost Chard." Sometimes the repeating situation that you find yourself stuck in every day is something you do not like, and you want it to end. And I guess like Bill Murray, who was caught on repeat in that old movie, you have to strategize and figure out how to minimize the unpleasantness. David Kestenbaum has this story about that.
第三幕，“寻找失落的甜菜。”有时，你每天陷入的重复处境是你不想经历的，而且你想让它结束。我想像比尔·默瑞一样，在那部老电影中被困在重复里，你必须制定策略，想出如何最小化这种不愉快。大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆有关于此的故事。
The garden was a thing of beauty. Jeff had just moved into a new house in Middletown, Delaware-- kind of a rural area. House did not have a garden, so he built one.
那个花园是个绝美之物。杰夫刚搬到特拉华州米德尔敦的一个新家——一个农村地区。房子没有花园，所以他建了一个。
Jeff is a do it yourself kind of guy-- handy with stuff, fixing cars, things around the house. The garden he makes is pretty big. He turns over all the soil, plants rows of seeds. It takes a long time.
杰夫是个“自己动手”类型的人——擅长处理事情，修理汽车，打理家务。他建造的花园相当大。他翻耕了所有土壤，种了一排排种子。这花了他很长时间。
It's really pristine. Everything's labeled. It backs up to a field, so it's pretty good scenery. Sometimes I'll just sit out there and just relax, look around, look at the different plants growing. It's really peaceful.
它真的很完美。所有东西都贴了标签。它背靠着一片田野，所以风景相当不错。有时我就坐在外面放松，四处看看，看看长出的不同植物。真的很宁静。
But gardening, as the writer Margaret Atwood has noted, is not a rational act. In nature, plants do not grow in tidy, pristine, labeled rows. In fact, nature does not care at all about your little setup.
但正如作家玛格丽特·阿特伍德所指出的，园艺不是一种理性的行为。在大自然中，植物不会长在整洁、原始、贴着标签的行里。事实上，大自然根本不在乎你的小布置。
Jeff was on vacation when it happened. A friend was watering his garden for him.
杰夫度假时事情发生了。一个朋友在帮他浇花园。
And he had called me. And he said, hey, man, something's eating all these plants. And he showed me a picture. And I was like, oh, man, that's horrible. So when I came back, I had noticed that my sweet potato plants were pretty much gone.
他给我打电话，说，嘿，伙计，有什么东西在吃这些植物。他给我看了张照片。我心想，哦，伙计，太糟糕了。所以我回来时，注意到我的红薯苗基本上都没了。
Not just the sweet potatoes.
不仅仅是红薯。
There was stuff-- chunks off the plants, off the fruits. The vegetables-- the tomatoes had chunks in them. Cucumbers had chunks in them.
东西被——从植物上，从果实上啃了一块块下来。蔬菜——番茄上有块被咬掉。黄瓜上有块被咬掉。
Chunks eaten out of them?
上面被啃了？
Yeah, just chunks missing randomly throughout the whole garden. It was like a selective process.
是的，整个花园里随机缺失了一些块。这就像是一个选择性的过程。
Jeff is really upset. He has no idea what is eating his vegetables, so he sets out a trap. One of those cage things that closes when an animal goes inside. And how did that work?
杰夫真的很生气。他不知道是什么在吃他的蔬菜，所以他设了个陷阱。那种动物进去后会自动关闭的笼子。那效果如何？
A complete failure.
彻底失败。
Goes out to check on the trap? Empty. Food in it? Untouched. What is eating the garden? Jeff runs through a list of possibilities.
出去检查陷阱？空的。里面有食物？没动过。什么在吃花园？杰夫列了一串可能性。
I thought it would be a deer. Maybe birds, rabbits, squirrels, or even a neighbor, a human.
我想可能是鹿。也许是鸟、兔子、松鼠，甚至可能是邻居，一个人。
Oh, a neighbor?
哦，邻居？
You never know, right? I mean, it could be anybody.
你永远不知道，对吧？我是说，可能是任何人。
Yeah, but--
是啊，但是——
I didn't know what it was.
我不知道那是什么。
One bite out of a tomato?
番茄被咬了一口？
I wouldn't put it past him.
我不会排除这个可能。
OK. I never lived where you live in Delaware, so I'll trust you.
好的。我没住在你住的特拉华州，所以我相信你。
Jeff thinks, enough with this. It really is driving him kind of mad. So he gets a motion detector camera. He borrows it from his brother, uses electrical tape to tape it to this old bucket he has and sticks it in the garden. It's one of those cameras that sends videos to your phone. So Jeff waits. He does not have to wait long.
杰夫心想，受够了。这真的让他快疯了。所以他买了一个运动探测摄像头。他从他兄弟那借来，用电工胶带把它贴在一个旧水桶上，然后插在花园里。那是那种把视频发送到手机的摄像头。所以杰夫等待着。他不需要等很久。
I'm at work. Actually, it was right at lunchtime. And I looked right at my phone because I got the notification. And I was really eager, like surprise. I went and I checked it.
我在工作。其实正好是午餐时间。我直接看了我的手机，因为我收到了通知。我真的很好奇，就像惊喜一样。我去看了一下。
And I just want to pause here to describe the cinematic perfection of this next moment. What Jeff sees at first in the video is nothing, like the camera's triggered off, something blowing in the breeze. You see a log in the background and the garden fence. And then a groundhog pops up with what appears to be a cucumber in its paws, rapidly chewing. It is staring right into the camera, head-on. It takes up the whole frame-- so close, you can hear it chewing.
我想在这里停一下，描述一下接下来这一刻的电影般完美。杰夫在视频里起初什么也没看到，摄像机触发了，有东西在微风中吹动。你可以看到背景里有一根木头和花园围栏。然后一只土拨鼠冒了出来，爪子里似乎拿着一根黄瓜，快速地咀嚼着。它正对着摄像头直视。它占据了整个画面——如此近，你可以听到它咀嚼的声音。
[GROUNDHOG CHEWING]
（土拨鼠咀嚼声）
Really funny to see. He's just got this look on his face. It was almost as if he was saying, yeah, it's me. I'm the one eating your garden up. What are you going to do about it?
看这个真的很好笑。它脸上就是那种表情。几乎就像它在说，是的，就是我。我就是那个吃光你花园的人。你打算怎么做？
What are you going to do about it?
你打算怎么做？
So at first when I saw it was a groundhog, I was like, oh, they dig. So I was like, I'll put the logs around.
起初当我看到是土拨鼠时，我心想，哦，它们挖洞。所以我心想，我把木头围在周围。
Like around the base of the fencing?
像围在围栏底部？
Around the base. Maybe that'll help. And no, it didn't. Then I was like, well, let me try to get a little bit more slick. And I would put, like, garden boundary, like landscape boundary, I would put it under the ground about maybe like a foot. So it'd be like a wall almost underground. And so even if they did dig, they'd hit the wall. And you'd think they would stop, right?
围在底部。也许那会有帮助。结果不，并没有。然后我心想，好吧，让我尝试再聪明一点。我会放园艺边界，比如景观边界，我会把它埋在地下大概一英尺深。所以它几乎就像地下的墙。即使它们挖洞，也会碰到墙。你会认为它们会停止，对吧？
Right.
对。
No. They just keep digging down until they got under it and then came back out the other side like it wasn't even there. So these are the kind of things I was dealing with, along with seeing him in the camera every day.
不。它们只是不停地往下挖，直到钻到下面，然后又从另一边钻出来，就像它根本不存在一样。所以这些就是我处理的事情，还有每天在摄像头里看到它。
Every day it was get up, drive to work, alert on phone, groundhog. Get up, drive to work, alert on phone, groundhog. The only thing that changed was the image-- groundhog with one of Jeff's tomatoes, groundhog with zucchini, groundhog with corn. Never peppers, somehow. Apparently, it didn't like peppers. He is in a Groundhog Day situation with an actual groundhog who, if he has to admit, is kind of cute.
每天都是起床、开车上班、手机提醒、土拨鼠。起床、开车上班、手机提醒、土拨鼠。唯一变的是画面——土拨鼠拿着杰夫的一个番茄，土拨鼠拿着西葫芦，土拨鼠拿着玉米。从来没有辣椒，不知怎么回事。显然它不喜欢辣椒。他陷入了现实版的《土拨鼠之日》，对象是一只真正的土拨鼠，如果他必须承认的话，它还挺可爱的。
So I said, you know what? I'm going to name you Chunk. It seemed very fitting because he was taking chunks out of the vegetables.
所以我说，你知道吗？我要叫你“大块头”（Chunk）。这听起来很贴切，因为它从蔬菜上咬下一块块的。
I feel like once you name the groundhog, you are crossing some kind of line, you know? I think you lost in that moment.
我觉得一旦你给土拨鼠起名，你就跨越了某种界限，你知道吗？我觉得在那一刻你输了。
Probably, in some senses.
可能，在某种意义上。
At some point, a female groundhog turns up. Presumably, she was Chunk's partner. Jeff names her Nibbles. But now he has two groundhogs. Weirdly, both of them would pop up on camera together, facing the same direction, each eating something of his.
在某个时候，一只母土拨鼠出现了。推测是“大块头”的伴侣。杰夫给她起名叫“啃啃”（Nibbles）。但现在他有两只土拨鼠了。奇怪的是，它们俩会一起出现在镜头里，脸朝同一个方向，各自吃着他的东西。
[GROUNDHOGS CHEWING]
（土拨鼠咀嚼声）
Jeff, desperate now, has one last idea for how to get out of this endless loop. And when I heard it, it seemed both adorable and completely unlikely to work. The following year, when it's time to plant the garden again, he goes out with his shovel, turns over more earth, and--
杰夫现在绝望了，他有一个最后的办法来跳出这个无尽的循环。当我听到时，它看起来既可爱又极其不可能成功。第二年，当该再次种植花园时，他带着铁锹出去，翻开更多泥土，然后——
I gave them their very own garden.
我给了它们自己的花园。
Oh my god.
哦，我的天。
Yeah, I literally planted them their own garden.
是的，我真的给它们种了一个属于它们自己的花园。
A reporter for the website The Dodo heard about the story. The resulting video is titled "Guy Builds Veggie Garden for Family of Groundhogs," which I saw and had questions about. That's why I called Jeff in the first place. I did not see how that was going to work.
网站The Dodo的一名记者听说了这个故事。由此产生的视频标题是“男人为土拨鼠一家建造蔬菜花园”，我看了之后有一些疑问。这就是我起初打电话给杰夫的原因。我不明白那怎么会有效。
Sure, now the groundhogs have their own garden that does not have some big fence around it. But wouldn't they eat their vegetables and then still break through the fencing into his like before? What's to stop them?
确实，现在土拨鼠有了自己的花园，没有围大栅栏。但它们难道不会吃完自己的蔬菜，然后像以前一样打破栅栏闯入他的花园吗？什么能阻止它们？
Did the plan actually work? If the goal was to get them to stay out of your garden, do they stay out of your garden?
那个计划真的奏效了吗？如果目标是让它们远离你的花园，它们真的远离了吗？
Yeah, for the most part because you give them their own plants around that are easier for them to get to, and then you secure yours up more to where it's more effort. And it's just like anyone, they're going to go for the easiest thing, right? The lowest hanging fruit.
是的，大多数情况下有效，因为你给它们提供了周围自己的植物，那些植物对它们来说更容易获取，然后你把你自己的围栏加固到更难突破。这就像任何人一样，它们会去追求最容易的东西，对吧？最低处的果实。
That's kind of genius, I have to say.
我不得不说，这有点天才。
It works.
它奏效了。
You said for the most part.
你说“大多数情况下”。
Well, I mean, yeah. There are times when they will still eat my vegetables, right? But it's not as bad, right? Because they got other options. But if they somehow happen to get into my garden, which they have-- especially the babies, because the babies are real small, so they can get in--
好吧，我是说，是的。有时它们还是会吃我的蔬菜，对吧？但没有那么糟糕，对吧？因为它们有其他选择。但如果它们不知怎么闯进了我的花园，它们也确实这么做过——尤其是幼崽，因为幼崽非常小，所以它们能钻进来——
Wait, wait. Babies?
等等，等等。幼崽？
Oh, yeah. Yeah, we have babies.
哦，是的。是的，我们有幼崽。
How many groundhogs do you have now?
你现在有多少只土拨鼠？
Seven.
七只。
I feel like you started out one place, and you ended up in a very different one.
我觉得你起初在一个地方，结果到了一个完全不同的地方。
Very. I embraced it. Especially with seeing him in the camera, it made it easy to give up. Seeing them in the camera every day, it eventually won my heart over.
确实。我接受了它。尤其是看到它在镜头里，这让放弃变得容易了。每天在镜头里看到它们，最终赢得了我的心。
Chunk is still there. Jeff last saw him in the fall. He's probably hibernating under the shed. It's been seven years at this point, which is old for a groundhog, though they can live longer. It helps to have a reliable food source.
“大块头”还在那里。杰夫上次看到它是在秋天。它可能在棚屋下冬眠。到目前为止已经七年了，这对土拨鼠来说很老了，尽管它们可以活得更久。有个可靠的食物来源很有帮助。
David Kestenbaum is our show's senior editor. Coming up, one man combats the chaos of the world on a narrow block in Brooklyn, week after week, every Tuesday and Thursday. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆是我们节目的资深编辑。接下来，一个男人在布鲁克林的一条窄街上对抗世界的混乱，周复一周，每个周二和周四。从芝加哥公共电台继续我们的节目，稍后回来。
This is This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, "Groundhog Day." Have you ever had a day that just seems to repeat again and again?
这里是《这一美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目，“土拨鼠日”。你是否曾有过那种日子似乎一遍又一遍重复的经历？
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme and bring you different kinds of stories on that theme.
这里是《这一美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们会选择一个主题，并为您带来各种各样的故事。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our show, of course, we choose a theme and bring you different kinds of stories on that theme.
Well, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, we choose a theme and bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme.
这里是《这一美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，我们会选择一个主题，并为您带来各种各样的故事。
Today's show, "Fiasco."
今天的节目，“惨败”。
Today on our program, "24 Hours at the Golden Apple."
今天在我们的节目中，“金苹果店的24小时”。
Today on our program, a story of race and politics in America-- the story of Harold Washington.
今天在我们的节目中，一个关于美国种族与政治的故事——哈罗德·华盛顿的故事。
Well, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's show, a special co-production with MPR News. A step by step look at what exactly happened during the subprime mortgage crisis.
这里是《这一美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目，与MPR新闻共同制作。一步步回顾次贷危机期间究竟发生了什么。
I'm Ira Glass. It's This American Life, the radio program that dares to ask the question--
我是艾拉·格拉斯。这里是《这一美国生活》，敢于提出那个问题的广播节目——
(SINGING) Parlez-vous francais?
（唱歌）你会说法语吗？
(SINGING) Mais oui, allons-y.
（唱歌）是的，我们走吧。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, "The Long Fuse."
这里是《这一美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目，“长引信”。
[EXPLOSION]
（爆炸声）
[CHUCKLES]
（轻笑）
I had forgotten about that one "The Long Fuse." Doing this theme this week, I have to admit, made me really think about what it feels like to do our program week after week, 853 times. This is our 853rd episode, and it does feel very different making this show for the 853rd time than it did at the very beginning. Definitely, there is a sameness to doing things again and again every week that is not entirely pleasant.
我差点忘了那个“长引信”。这周做这个主题，我必须承认，让我真的思考每周一遍又一遍地做我们的节目是什么感觉，853次。这是我们的第853集，第853次制作这个节目感觉确实与刚开始时大不相同。绝对地，每周一遍又一遍地做事有一种并不完全令人愉快的重复感。
But, of course, while the process of making a show is always the same, the content of the show changes so much. And there's just something about-- I don't know how to put it-- like, it's creating the little dream that radio can be. It always-- I don't know, it just gets to me. When the music enters.
但是，当然，虽然制作节目的过程总是相同的，但节目的内容却发生了很大的变化。而且这其中有某种——我不知道怎么说——就像是创造了广播可能成为的那种小梦。它总是——我不知道，它就是触动了我。当音乐响起时。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
（音乐响起）
Thank you for that. Everything you say just sounds smarter when you're saying it over music. And just making all the little parts of the show perfect, or at least as obsessively perfect as you can make it. It's just so easy to get lost in that, even on the 853rd time.
谢谢你。你所说的一切在音乐响起时听起来都更聪明。只要让节目的每一个小部分都完美，或者至少达到你所能达到的那种强迫症般的完美。即使在第853次，也太容易沉浸在其中了。
Act 4, "Heart of Parkness." People who own cars in certain cities really are just asking for pain. Certain cities are not set up for them and deliver regular, repeated punishment to car owners. Valerie Kipnis's hometown definitely does that on a schedule that's literally posted on signs.
第四幕，“公园之心”。在某些城市拥有汽车的人真的是在自找痛苦。某些城市不是为它们设置的，并给车主带来定期的、重复的惩罚。瓦莱丽·基普尼斯的家乡确实按告示牌上写的时间表这样做。
Growing up in New York, you get used to the fact that for a few days every week, your street becomes total chaos. That's because the street cleaning truck is scheduled to come through. The first day, you can't park on the left-hand side, so the sweeper can drive down that way. The second day, you can't park on the right. And it's not like there are empty spaces on other blocks you can move your car to.
在纽约长大，你习惯了这样一个事实：每周有几天，你的街道会陷入彻底的混乱。这是因为清扫街道的卡车计划会经过。第一天，你不能把车停在左侧，这样清扫车就可以开过去。第二天，你不能停在右侧。这并不是说其他街区有空位你可以挪车过去。
So all over New York, what people do on street cleaning day is double park. They move their car so it's sitting next to the row of parked cars on the other side. And then they just leave their cars there, double parked, unattended, in the middle of the street for 1 and 1/2 hours, making room for the street cleaner to sweep next to the curb where their car had just sat. 8 million people, and this is the system we use.
所以，在纽约各地，人们在街道清扫日做的就是双排停车。他们挪动车，使它停在另一侧停放的一排车旁边。然后他们就把车留在那，双排停放，无人看管，在街中间停上一个半小时，为清扫车腾出空间，清扫刚才他们车停的地方。800万人，这就是我们使用的系统。
A few years ago, I moved to a new neighborhood where the situation is even more intense. The street I live on now is incredibly narrow, just under 25 feet across. I know because I measured, which means that if you don't double park perfectly, very close to the row of already parked cars, you end up blocking all traffic. No cars, no street cleaner can get through. And if one neighbor doesn't come out and move their car, that can block all traffic too.
几年前，我搬到了一个情况更严重的新社区。我现在住的这条街非常窄，宽不到25英尺。我知道因为我测量过，这意味着如果你没有完美地双排停车，离已经停好的一排车很近，你最终会阻挡所有交通。没有车、清扫车能通过。如果有一个邻居没出来挪车，那也会阻挡所有交通。
But this new street I live on also came with something I'd never seen before-- a guy who twice a week has made it his job to try to make this all run smoothly. His persistence, his dedication to this thankless job has always sort of puzzled me, so I went out with him on a Thursday this fall. His name is David, in his 50s, a former Marine-- and, as it happens, my landlord. It's a few minutes before 11:30 when the whole thing begins on our street. David's wearing his usual uniform of a crisp gray cotton T-shirt and basketball shorts.
但我住的这条新街也带有些我从未见过的东西——一个每周两次把让一切顺利运行当作自己工作的人。他的执着，他对这份吃力不讨好工作的奉献，一直让我感到困惑，所以我在今年秋天的一个周四和他一起出去。他的名字是大卫，50多岁，前海军陆战队队员——碰巧，也是我的房东。在我们街上，整个事情开始前几分钟，大约是11点半。大卫穿着他通常的制服：一件干练的灰色棉T恤和篮球短裤。
11:30, just get in your cars and double park them and everything works like a charm. Brandon, how are you? They're going to be moving their cars now, you hear me? I'm becoming like chiaccheron.
11点半，只要把车开进来双排停好，一切就会像魔术一样运行。布兰登，你好吗？他们现在要挪车了，你听见了吗？我快变成长舌妇了。
A blabbermouth. David always worries he's coming on too strong.
一个爱说话的人。大卫总是担心他表现得太强势。
Yeah, so he's moving now. The guy in the white car is moving. Bob's moving. You'll all be able to put your cars right down there.
是啊，所以他现在在挪车了。白色汽车里的那个人在挪车。鲍勃在挪车。你们所有人都能把车停在那儿。
His goal this morning is to get everyone on the left side neatly double parking down the middle of our street. To do this, he tries to know everyone on the block. Which cars belong to who? Who tends to run late? Who runs early? Who's new around here? Who needs a reminder?
他今天早上的目标是让左侧的每个人都在我们街中间整齐地双排停车。为了做到这一点，他试图认识街上的每个人。哪些车属于谁？谁倾向于迟到？谁起得早？谁是新来的？谁需要提醒？
Like, let me read you some of our most recent texts. Hey, Valerie, it's time for the car. Hey, Valerie, is that your car across the street? Hey, Valerie, don't forget about the car. Today, I'm on time.
比如，让我读给你听我们最近的一些短信。嘿，瓦莱丽，该挪车了。嘿，瓦莱丽，街对面那是你的车吗？嘿，瓦莱丽，别忘了车。今天，我很准时。
You know what? You should go right between there.
你知道吗？你应该停在那两个中间。
Oh. Well, this guy's going to leave right now. I think so.
哦。好吧，那个人现在就要走了。我想是的。
Yeah, he's waiting for his wife. But you go right behind James.
是啊，他在等他老婆。但你可以停在詹姆斯后面。
Where are you going to pull up?
你要把车停在哪里？
I'm going to see what I got to do.
我得看看我该做什么。
David's got a black Grand Cherokee Jeep. It's about midway up the block.
大卫有一辆黑色大切诺基吉普车。它在街区中间位置。
Because I'm going to either pull up on the sidewalk right here.
因为我要么把车停在这儿的人行道上。
[CAR HORN]
（汽车鸣笛声）
Tell him to move in or whatever it is.
告诉他挪进去还是别的什么。
Oh, no. The honking's started.
哦，不。喇叭声开始了。
Yeah, you're going to have to--
是啊，你得——
All right. I'm moving my car.
好吧。我挪我的车。
He spots James, our neighbor, who just walked out of his house.
他发现了詹姆斯，我们的邻居，他刚从家里走出来。
How are you, James? Yeah, we're double parking now. So we're trying to make a plan. James, she's going to move her car now, too, so you might as well-- if you want to pull right here for now. And she's going to move, and then you could follow suit.
你好，詹姆斯。是的，我们在双排停车。所以我们在尝试制定一个计划。詹姆斯，她现在也要挪车了，所以你最好——如果你现在想停在这儿。她要挪车，然后你可以跟进。
David nods his head in the direction of my car, like, come on, enough with the interview.
大卫朝我的车点了点头，意思好像是说，得了吧，采访够了吧。
All right, I'm moving, I'm moving.
好吧，我在挪，我在挪。
It's a really tight parking job. You have to get so close to the car on the other side of the street that your side view mirrors touch.
这是一个非常紧凑的停车位。你必须离街对面的车非常近，以至于后视镜都碰在一起。
Now we back up. Just back up about another-- I'll tell you when to stop.
现在我们倒车。再往后退一点——我会告诉你什么时候停。
All right.
好的。
Just watch his side. Don't get-- yeah, you're good, you're good.
注意他的侧面。别——是的，你很好，你很好。
Sometimes when I don't do a good job, David will offer to help, grab my keys, and repark the car for me. Today, I do OK. He lets it be.
有时当我做得不好时，大卫会提议帮忙，抓过我的钥匙，替我重新停车。今天，我做得还行。他放过了我。
It's a couple minutes past 11:30 when all the cars are supposed to have been moved, but only a few have. A few other neighbors, one holding a toddler, the other clearly on a work call, have started coming out of their houses. David waves at them and signals for them to move their cars. We've still got time before the street sweeper comes.
过了11点半几分钟，所有车本该挪好了，但只有几辆挪了。其他几个邻居，一个抱着幼儿，另一个显然在处理工作电话，开始从房子里出来。大卫向他们挥手示意，暗示他们挪车。在清扫车来之前我们还有时间。
What are you going to do?
你打算做什么？
I got to sit in the car.
我得坐在车里。
OK, I'm going to sit with you, then.
好吧，那我跟你一起坐。
We climb in. He double parks. Before David started doing this job, when he was still just a kid growing up on the block, someone else did it. He was a local legend, a guy named Eddie.
我们爬了进去。他双排停放。在大卫开始做这份工作之前，当他还是个在街区长大的孩子时，另一个人在做。那是个当地传奇，一个叫埃迪的家伙。
Like, years ago, Eddie Demaio was-- We called him the mayor. We were kids, and we used to sit there and just watch him, like he's out of his mind.
就像，几年前，埃迪·德马约是——我们叫他市长。我们还是孩子时，我们常坐在那儿看着他，感觉他疯了。
One old-timer on the block told me, hey, don't make a hero out of Eddie. Apparently, he was a complicated guy. He would sit in a lawn chair in the street so that cars couldn't get through. He once laid down in the road to save a parking spot for his daughter-in-law. But still, he kept things in order.
街区里的一位老住户告诉我，嘿，别把埃迪捧成英雄。显然，他是个复杂的人。他会在街上摆一把草坪椅，这样车就过不去了。他曾经躺在马路上为他儿媳保存一个停车位。但即便如此，他还是保持了秩序。
Like the chess master, you go there, you go here. You go in there, you're going to make it easier for him to pull over there. He's going to come out now. He's going to pull behind you-- and everything works.
就像国际象棋大师，你走那里，你走这儿。你停在那儿，会让他更容易停过去。他现在要出来了。他会停在你后面——一切就搞定了。
Oh, I know someone who does something just like that, David.
哦，我认识一个做类似事情的人，大卫。
Yeah, I know. I became that person.
是啊，我知道。我变成了那个人。
Actually, it wasn't like David just became that person. When Eddie got old, he actually passed the mantle to David.
实际上，并不是大卫直接变成了那个人。当埃迪老了之后，他实际上把衣钵传给了大卫。
Years ago, he goes, Dave, you take the helm.
几年前，他说，戴夫，你来掌舵。
But it's gotten harder. When Eddie was the street parking conductor, most houses had one car and the neighbors all knew each other, were all on board with this parking system. They'd grab the keys and move the car for one another. But recently, this block has really changed. Something like a quarter of the houses have been sold to new folks.
但这变得更难了。当埃迪是街头停车指挥时，大多数房子有一辆车，邻居们都互相认识，也都同意这个停车系统。他们会拿过钥匙帮彼此挪车。但最近，这个街区发生了很大变化。大约四分之一的房子被卖给了新住户。
It used to be a blue collar, Italian neighborhood. Now it's got people with enough money to throw millions of dollars into buying and renovating entire brownstones. On street cleaning day, the new people seem happy to leave their cars and get a ticket. And also because of the renovations, there are constantly trucks parked on the street which take up space in this game of parking Tetris. Michelle, one of our neighbors, walks past us looking frustrated. David points to her and shakes his head.
过去这是个蓝领意大利社区。现在这里的人有足够的钱投入数百万美元购买和翻新整栋棕色砂岩建筑。在街道清扫日，新来的人似乎乐意留下他们的车并吃罚单。而且由于翻修，街上总是停着卡车，在这个停车俄罗斯方块游戏中占用了空间。米歇尔，我们的邻居之一，带着沮丧走过我们身边。大卫指着她，摇了摇头。
Michelle. She's looking for a double park spot now. And she lives on the block. It's ridiculous.
米歇尔。她正在找双排停车位。她就住在街区里。这太荒谬了。
Michelle can't double park her car because there's a Tesla in front of her that hasn't moved in a couple of weeks, and there's a construction dumpster behind her. If she pulls into the spot in the middle lane that's across from where she is right now, she'll block the entire street. This kind of stuff happens all the time. And David knows how he sounds saying this-- like some old guy at the park feeding the pigeons and complaining. His words, not mine. But it really didn't use to be this way.
米歇尔不能双排停车，因为她前面有一辆特斯拉已经好几周没动了，她后面有个施工垃圾箱。如果她停进她现在对面中间车道的空位，她会堵死整条街。这种事经常发生。大卫知道他这么说听起来是什么样——就像公园里喂鸽子并抱怨的老头。他的话，不是我的。但这真的过去不是这样。
Parking, it's-- We grew up a certain way. We learned a certain way how to handle yourself and to be courteous-- look out for your family, your neighbors. Everybody on your block was like family.
停车，它——我们以某种方式长大。我们以某种方式学会了如何举止得体——照顾你的家人，你的邻居。你们街区的每个人都像家人一样。
OK. And now what is it?
好的。那现在是什么？
What is it now? I'm trying to think of a word. It's empty.
现在是什么？我正在试图想一个词。它是空的。
Empty.
空的。
God forbid there's an ambulance that's coming up. A fire truck-- if there's a fire, you're just causing such-- you never know who has someone sick, who has an infant in their car that has to get home, who has appointments-- serious stuff. You never know who's having a bad day.
老天保佑，如果有救护车要过来。消防车——如果有火灾，你制造了如此——你永远不知道谁有生病的家人，谁的车里有需要回家的婴儿，谁有预约——严肃的事情。你永远不知道谁在经历糟糕的一天。
In the last two years, David's had five family members die. Three of them lived here with David in this house, on this block. He took care of them, and it was a lot.
在过去两年里，大卫有五位家人去世。其中三人和大卫住在这栋房子里，就在这个街区。他照顾他们，这很辛苦。
Whether it's a nursing home, whether it's hospice, whether it's changing bandages or the oxygen machine that can-- changing the water, making sure there's water in the cup, bedsores, doctors, back and forth to the hospital, watching somebody die.
无论是养老院，还是临终关怀，无论是更换绷带还是氧气机，可以——更换水，确保杯子里有水，褥疮，医生，来来回回医院，看着某人死去。
I just think that you are taking care of so much.
我只是觉得你承担了太多。
No.
不。
Yes, you are, David. You're taking care of-- you were taking care of Joan. You had your dad. Now you've got your mom. You're taking care of the house.
是的，你有，大卫。你在照顾——你在照顾琼。你有你爸爸。现在你还有你妈妈。你在照顾房子。
My Aunt Phil, yeah.
我菲尔阿姨，是啊。
Your Aunt Phil.
你菲尔阿姨。
Listen--
听着——
But wait, let me finish. I think there's so much things that are happening in the house. I feel like I live in it, so I see it. A lot of stuff's out of your control, but this parking thing-- you're like, can we just get this right?
但等等，让我说完。我认为房子里发生了很多事情。我觉得我住在这里，所以我看到了。很多事情超出了你的控制，但这个停车的事——你在想，我们能不能把这件事搞定？
Know what it is? It's something that's not hard. It's a neighborhood thing. It's a block thing. Just do the right thing, and everything falls into place.
知道那是什么吗？这不是什么难事。这是一个社区的事情。这是一个街区的事情。只要做正确的事，一切就会各就各位。
11:45. We get out of the car to check on how the parking is going down the block, and immediately it's clear there's a problem. There's a truck that can't get through with a growing line of cars behind it. No way the street cleaner is going to make it through here.
11点45分。我们下车去检查街区那头的停车情况，显而易见出了问题。有一辆卡车后面跟着一长串车过不去。清扫车绝对不可能从这儿通过。
It's going-- It's 3/4 of a block long.
它正在——它有四分之三个街区那么长。
It's actually chaos. I'm looking right now. The parking-- now everyone's going to start honking.
这实际上是混乱。我正看着呢。停车——现在每个人都要开始鸣笛了。
Yeah, there's cars backed up around the corner. You have-- Let's see, you have about 30 cars.
是啊，车一直排到了拐角处。你大约有——让我们看看，大约有30辆车。
The problem? On our block, a construction crew has left a barricade of giant plastic orange traffic barriers in the street to hold space for their dump truck. The barriers are on the street cleaning side by the sidewalk, and near them, in the middle of the street, someone has parked their car. No name, no number on the dashboard. There is no room for anyone to squeeze through.
问题？在我们街区，一个建筑队在街上留下了一道巨大的塑料橙色交通路障，为他们的自卸卡车保留空间。路障在人行道边的街道清扫侧，在它们附近，在街中间，有人把车停在那。没有名字，仪表盘上没有号码。没有人能挤过去。
You know, this is crazy. It's crazy.
你知道，这太疯狂了。太疯狂了。
Now he's taking up three spots
现在他占了三个车位。
Now he's taking up three spots.
For a split moment, David isn't sure what to do. Then a couple other old-timers, our neighbor Bob and this guy Kenny, approach him and they huddle off to the side. I look at them and back to the street. Any minute now and the honking will start. The chaos will ensue. It's tense. The three of them consider their options.
片刻间，大卫不知道该怎么办。然后其他几个老住户，我们的邻居鲍勃和那个叫肯尼的家伙，靠近他，他们聚在边上。我看着他们，又看着街道。任何时候喇叭声都会开始。混乱将会随之而来。气氛很紧张。他们三个考虑着选择。
Yeah, those things are usually filled up with water.
是啊，那些东西通常里面装满了水。
Yeah, I know.
是啊，我知道。
They weigh--
它们重——
Are they?
它们装了吗？
They-- Well, there's some water in it because they're not light. And if they were totally filled with water, it would weigh a ton.
它们——嗯，里面有一些水，因为它们并不轻。如果它们完全装满水，那将重达一吨。
Meaning the barriers are going to be super heavy, like hundreds of pounds. But they've got to try to do something anyway. So the three of them go over to the barriers, which are too heavy to lift, and try to drag them off the road.
意思是路障会非常重，像几百磅。但无论如何他们必须尝试做点什么。于是他们三个走到路障旁，那些太重搬不动，就试图把它们拖离路面。
[GROANING]
（呻吟声）
Hey, they're locked into each other?
嘿，它们是锁在一起的吗？
I'd put them in on his lawn.
我会把它们放在他的草坪上。
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
Now they're clogging up the sidewalk.
现在它们堵住人行道了。
Hey, baby.
嘿，宝贝。
David, that looks pretty heavy.
大卫，那看起来很重。
Yeah, it's got weight.
是啊，有重量。
This is constructive vandalism. We're helping each other, like local heroes, hey?
这是建设性的破坏。我们像当地英雄一样在互相帮助，嘿？
It takes a while, but they manage to drag the barriers next to the lawn of the house undergoing construction.
花了一点时间，但他们设法把路障拖到了正在施工的房子草坪旁边。
Now we have enough space. We have enough street there for one car.
现在我们有足够的空间了。我们街上有足够一辆车通过的空间。
The truck is able to get through. The line of cars finally starts to move, and then after them comes the street sweeper. Sweet, sweet victory.
卡车能够通过了。车队终于开始移动，接着后面是清扫车。甜美的、甜美的胜利。
[ENGINE RUMBLING]
（引擎轰鸣声）
It swerves around the unmoved Tesla and the three other cars that no one cared to move, but makes it through nonetheless. There's no celebration, no moment of victory. David heads out to pick up his mom's meds, then he comes back to feed the birds because he actually does that. In a bit, David gets in his car and moves it back to the left side of the road, checks and makes sure I reparked mine correctly, that the others have, too.
它绕过了那辆没挪动的特斯拉和其他三辆没人想挪的车，但无论如何还是通过了。没有庆祝，没有胜利的时刻。大卫前往取他妈妈的药，然后他回来喂鸟，因为他确实会做那个。一会儿，大卫上车，把车挪回道路左侧，检查并确保我正确地重新停好了我的车，其他人也一样。
The barriers will reappear overnight, except this time, they'll take up more space. David, Bob, and Kenny will push them to the sidewalk again and then again. The Tesla won't move. The neighbors will be late. Every week, the cycle will repeat itself. This little universe will break apart and David will put it back together again.
路障会在一夜之间重新出现，只是这一次，它们会占用更多空间。大卫、鲍勃和肯尼会再次把它们推到人行道，然后再次这样。特斯拉不会动。邻居们会迟到。每周，循环都会重复。这个小宇宙会破碎，而大卫会再次把它拼凑起来。
Valerie Kipnis is a producer on our show.
瓦莱丽·基普尼斯是我们节目的制作人。
Act Five, "It's Been a Hard Year's Night, and I've Been Working Like a Hog." So Punxsutawney Phil is not the only groundhog who gets drafted into annual Groundhog Day ceremonies around the country. There's actually a website, groundhog-day.com, that lists over three dozen of these poor critters around the United States and Canada. There's French Creek Freddie in West Virginia, Woody the Woodchuck in Michigan. There's a groundhog in New York City at the Staten Island Zoo.
第五幕，“又是难熬的一年，我像只土拨鼠一样工作。”所以，菲尔不是唯一一个在全国各地被征召参加土拨鼠日仪式的土拨鼠。实际上有一个网站，groundhog-day.com，列出了美国和加拿大各地三打以上的这些可怜生物。西弗吉尼亚州有“小溪弗雷迪”，密歇根州有“伍迪土拨鼠”。在纽约市的史泰登岛动物园里有一只土拨鼠。
In New York, in the past, the city's mayor used to be part of the groundhog ceremony till 2015, after Bill de Blasio dropped a groundhog. It died later that same week. The current mayor, Eric Adams, is a well-known rodent hater who launched a war on the city's rats, and he has never shown up in person to the ceremony. And as the man who runs the city, he could use his powers to try to shut down the Groundhog Day ceremony on Staten Island once and for all.
在纽约，过去，该市市长曾参加土拨鼠仪式，直到2015年比尔·白思豪摔死了一只土拨鼠。那只土拨鼠在同一周晚些时候死掉了。现任市长埃里克·亚当斯是一个众所周知的啮齿动物仇恨者，他对城市的老鼠发起了战争，他本人从未亲自参加过仪式。作为城市的领导者，他本可以利用权力彻底关闭史泰登岛的土拨鼠日仪式。
And there's somebody out there who would like that very much. We are pleased to bring her to you now. This is a This American Life exclusive. She is a resident of New York, specifically Staten Island-- more specifically, the zoo.
外面有人非常希望这样做。我们很高兴现在把她介绍给你。这是一次《这一美国生活》的独家报道。她是纽约的居民，特别是史泰登岛——更具体地说，住在动物园里。
Dear Mayor Adams, I'm the groundhog. My name is Susan. I'm nine years old. I have 48 children. None of them are potty trained. All of them need braces. Their fathers are always digging and never helping.
亲爱的亚当斯市长，我是那只土拨鼠。我的名字叫苏珊。我九岁了。我有48个孩子。没有一个学会了用便盆。所有人都需要牙齿矫正。他们的父亲总是挖洞，从不帮忙。
All eight of my nipples are unrecognizable. I haven't ever taken a shower, and I'm at the end of my goddamn rope. You call it Groundhog Day, but have you ever considered what I, the groundhog, actually want?
我所有的八个乳头都认不出来了。我从来没洗过澡，我到了忍无可忍的地步。你们称之为土拨鼠日，但你们有没有考虑过我，这只土拨鼠，真正想要什么？
Do you even know who I am besides some nameless creature you can foist in the air for a photo op? Do you have any idea what I sacrifice for you all? Because when I think about it, from the time I turned two and started having litters of tiny, hairless babies, I have been expected every year to decide the fate of the Northern Hemisphere of the planet.
你甚至知道除了某种可以让你作为照片宣传工具的无名生物外，我是谁吗？你知道我为你们所有人牺牲了什么吗？因为当我想到它时，从我两岁开始生下一窝窝小小的、没毛的幼崽时，我就被期待着每年决定地球北半球的命运。
And not that you have time to even look it up between all your various staged perp walks, but I'm supposed to hibernate from October to April-- from October to April. That's when the rest of my family sleeps. And it's supposed to be when I am finally able to get some rest. Those months, I'm supposed to be out cold, like you-- one Valium deep in a lay-flat business class seat on Turkish Airlines.
并不是说你有时间在各种摆拍的逮捕行动之间甚至查阅一下，但我应该从十月到四月冬眠——从十月到四月。那是我的家人的休息时间。那应该是我终于可以得到一点休息的时候。那些月份，我应该睡得死死的，就像你一样——在土耳其航空公司的平躺商务舱座位上，喝下一片安定药。
Do you have any idea how exhausting it is to be me? 48 children, and they all co-sleep-- judge me-- so I'm kicked by 192 tiny feet all night, every night. And yet, the first week of February, you and your mayor friends are going to yank me out of my burrow because, surprise-- nobody knows how to do anything for five goddamn months without waking up mom.
你知道成为我是多么令人精疲力竭吗？48个孩子，而且他们都跟我一起睡——评判我吧——所以我每晚、每晚被192只小脚踢。然而，在二月的第一周，你和你的市长朋友们要把我从洞穴里拽出来，因为，惊喜——没有人知道如何在不吵醒妈妈的情况下做五个月的任何事情。
So will there be six more weeks of winter? Did you see your shadow? Yeah, I see my shadow every time I look in a mirror because I am a shadow of my former self. They never even ask me if I saw it. They just presume whether or not I saw my shadow based on whether I wrinkle my snout at the ground.
所以会有六周的冬天吗？你看到你的影子了吗？是的，我每次照镜子都能看到我的影子，因为我是我过去自己的影子。他们甚至从没问过我是不是看到了。他们只是根据我是否对地面皱起鼻子，来推测我是不是看到了我的影子。
This whole holiday, which is supposed to be about me, is predicated on a group of mouth-breathing men in top hats deciding whether or not I was capable of seeing my own shadow. And then they hold me up and shout in my face and then blind me with flashbulbs. But I don't feel seen at all. And I never get an apology. And I never get a thank you.
整个假期，本应该是关于我的，却是建立在一群戴着大礼帽、用嘴呼吸的男人决定我是否有能力看到自己影子之上。然后他们举起我，对着我的脸大喊，然后用闪光灯闪瞎我。但我一点也没觉得被看见。而且我从来没得到过道歉。而且我从来没得到过一声谢谢。
And by the way, I want everyone to stop calling me a groundhog. A ground hog? That's not even a species. It's an insult. It's calling me dirt pig. Did you know in Canada, I'm called a marmot? That's dignified, that's chic. That's apres-ski.
顺便说一句，我希望每个人都别再叫我“土拨鼠”（groundhog）。土拨鼠？那甚至不是一个物种。这是一种侮辱。这简直是叫我脏猪。你知道在加拿大，我被叫作“土拨鼠”（marmot）吗？那很尊贵，那很时髦。那是滑雪后的感觉。
OK, I hear myself. I know how I sound. I sound exactly like my mother and her mother before her. I come from a proud line of groundhogs who have done this job year after year, and I'm not here to complain. No. Whatever I say, I know it's not going to make a difference. It doesn't matter.
好吧，我听见我自己说话了。我知道我听起来像什么。我听起来和我母亲以及她之前的母亲一模一样。我来自一个引以为豪的土拨鼠血统，他们年复一年做这份工作，我不是来抱怨的。不。不管我说什么，我知道这不会有任何改变。这没关系。
[LIGHTER FLICKS]
（打火机声）
[SIZZLING]
（嘶嘶声）
I can play my role. I can smile and go through the motions, and for one February morning, let you have a moment of pure escapism, however dumb and degrading and exhausting as it is for me. So go ahead, [PUFFS SMOKE] play the trombones, unfurl your little scroll, and have your weird rodent fortune-telling pageant, because you need it. So send in the clown.
我可以扮演我的角色。我可以微笑，走过场，在二月的早晨，让你们获得纯粹的逃避现实时刻，尽管对我来说这很愚蠢、卑微和令人精疲力竭。所以继续吧，（喷出一口烟）吹响长号，展开你们的小卷轴，举办你们奇怪的啮齿动物算命选美大会吧，因为你们需要它。所以让小丑上场吧。
And when you lift me, your groundhog, high into the air, I will look into the crowd and see your vulnerable, yearning human faces staring back at me, standing out in the cold, just desperate to see something that breaks up the gray monotony of your repetitive lives. Trudging in your little puffer jackets, staring at your phones to go sit at a desk and eat a salad every day.
当你把我，你们的土拨鼠，高高举向空中时，我会看向人群，看到你们脆弱、渴望的人类脸庞回望着我，站在寒冷中，只是绝望地想要看到一些能打破你们重复生活中灰暗单调的东西。穿着你们的小羽绒夹克蹒跚而行，盯着手机，每天去坐在桌子旁吃沙拉。
And then you look up, and there I am, the groundhog. When you cheer for me, you are cheering for your own hope that if this ridiculous tradition can endure, maybe you can, too. May it be a happy Groundhog Day for us all. Sincerely, Susan Hog-Kaplowitz.
然后你们抬头看，我就是那里，土拨鼠。当你们为我欢呼时，你们是在为你们自己的希望欢呼：如果这种荒谬的传统能延续下去，也许你们也可以。愿这对我们所有人来说都是一个快乐的土拨鼠日。诚挚地，苏珊·霍格-卡普洛维茨。
Susan Hog-Kaplowitz's letter to Mayor Adams was written and read by Bess Kalb. She writes books and other funny stuff. Her newsletter, which you can find on Substack, is The Grudge Report.
苏珊·霍格-卡普洛维茨写给亚当斯市长的信由贝丝·卡尔布撰写和阅读。她写书和其他有趣的东西。她的通讯简报，你可以在Substack上找到，叫《怨恨报告》。
["STUCK ON THE TREADMILL" BY RICHARD THOMPSON]
（理查德·汤普森演唱《困在跑步机上》）
(SINGING) Well, our money goes out, the bills come in
（唱歌）嗯，我们的钱流出去，账单进来了
Round and round, we go again
一圈又一圈，我们又回到了原点
I come close, but I never win
我接近了，但我从没赢过
I'm stuck on the treadmill.
我被困在跑步机上了。
Another day of punching steel till my arm's too numb to feel
又是一天疯狂地工作直到手臂麻木得没感觉
Like a hamster on a wheel, I'm stuck on a treadmill
像轮子上的仓鼠，我被困在跑步机上了
Well, our program was produced today by Aviva DeKornfeld. The people who put together today's program include Bim Adewunmi, Jendayi Bonds, Dana Chivvis, Michael Carmody, Angelo Giavazzi, Chana Joffe-Walt, Tobin Low, Miki Meek, Katherine Rae Mondo, Stowe Nelson, Nadia Reiman, Ryan Rumery, Lilly Sullivan, Frances Swanson, Christopher Swetala, Julie Whitaker, and Diane Wu.
嗯，我们的节目今天由阿维瓦·德科恩菲尔德制作。今天参与制作节目的工作人员包括比姆·阿德温米、詹达伊·邦兹、达娜·奇维斯、迈克尔·卡莫迪、安吉洛·贾瓦齐、查娜·乔夫-沃尔特、托宾·洛、米基·米克、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、斯托·尼尔森、纳迪亚·雷曼、瑞安·鲁梅里、莉莉·沙利文、弗朗西斯·斯旺森、克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉、朱莉·惠特克和黛安·吴。
Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman and our senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry. Special thanks today to Keri Rose Tiessen, Ethan Brooks, Eddie Huang, Lindiwe Dlamini, Saori Tsukada, Avery Trufelman, and Ned Ryerson.
我们的管理编辑是萨拉·阿卜杜勒拉赫曼，资深编辑是大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆。我们的执行编辑是埃马努埃莱·贝里。今天特别感谢凯莉·罗斯·蒂森、伊桑·布鲁克斯、埃迪·黄、林迪韦·德拉米尼、织田沙织、艾弗里·特鲁费尔曼和内德·雷耶森。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. To become a This American Life Partner-- it gets you bonus episodes. It gets you ad-free listening. It gets you hundreds of greatest hits episodes that show up right in your podcast feed-- go to thisamericanlife.org/lifepartners. Also very important-- signing up this way also helps keep our program going.
《这一美国生活》通过PRX（公共广播交换中心）提供给公共广播电台。要成为《这一美国生活》合作伙伴——这能让你获得奖励剧集。它能让你获得无广告收听体验。它能让你获得数百集就在你的播客订阅源中呈现的热门经典剧集——请前往thisamericanlife.org/lifepartners。也非常重要——通过这种方式注册也有助于维持我们的节目。
Thanks as always to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, he is not a very good dance teacher.
一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人，托里·马拉蒂亚先生。你知道，他不是一个非常好的舞蹈老师。
You go there, you go here. With you going there, you're going to make it easier for him to pull over there. He's going to come out now. He's going to pull behind you, and everything works.
你走那里，你走这儿。你停在那儿，会让他更容易停过去。他现在要出来了。他会停在你后面，一切就搞定了。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周回来，带来更多《这一美国生活》的故事。